[موسيقى]
قرية التصويت في DEFCON هي
فريق التقييم المستقل الوحيد التابع لطرف ثالث
لآلات التصويت على حد علمنا في
العالم بأسره ، لذلك يأتي الناس إلى هنا
ليبدأوا فعلاً في معرفة
كيفية عمل هذه الآلات بالضبط ما
هي نقاط الضعف حتى نتمكن من  إجراء
انتخابات أكثر أمانًا ، نعم ، هناك مليون
طريقة مختلفة للتفاعل
[موسيقى] ،
هذا هو برنامج TSX المستخدم في
18 ولاية مختلفة ، ثماني منها
حالات متأرجحة ، ستبدأ إعادة التشغيل
وستجد أنها تواجه مشكلة في
إعادة التشغيل لأنه لا يوجد
المكربن والآن لديك وصول إداري كامل على هذ
الجهاز حتى تتمكن من نقل الانتخابات فقط ، يم
نك تشويه ثق
الناس في الانتخابات عندما تف
ر في وصول المسؤول ، يمكنك التفكير في مف
تيح القلعة عندما يك
ن لديك وصول إداري ، فأنت تمتلك ال
هاز  يمكنك جعلها تفعل ما تريد أن
تفعله حتى تتخيل أن
اختياراتك شديدة التعقيد
بحيث لا يمكننا نحن البشر أن نفعل مانو  جميع الكونت
نحن غير أمناء ونحن فخورون ، لذلك
يتعين علينا استخدام الآلات بينما نعلم
أن الأفضل هو قابليتنا للاختراق ، لذا
فالسؤال الآن هو أننا نستخدم الجهاز والآن
نتحقق من النتائج من خلال إجراء
تدقيق للحد من المخاطر وهذا هو المكان الذي يمكنك فيه
اعلم أن الآلة لم تغش ولكن
لا يمكنك الوثوق بالآلة باعتبارها رصيدًا فارغًا للورق
[موسيقى]